- You had to come with
a lil' bit more
than just the best players.
All them people that they say
are the best to ever do it—
- Yeah?
- My teams beat all them.
- Welcome to Full-Bodied.
I'm Channing Frye.
As the wines get darker, the
questions gonna get deeper.
Let's go.
Isiah Thomas. Zeke.
Coach. Boss. Mentor.
First of all, thank you so much
for taking the time to be here
with us on Full-Bodied.
It's amazing to me to be able
to open up another African
American man's Champagne.
- Oh, most definitely.
This is one of my
favorite things
about being in the Champagne
and the wine spaces,
that you get to, you know,
pop and drink and sip.
And you get to have
great conversation.
- Where did this idea or
opportunity come from?
You're an inner-city
kid from Chicago, and you're—
are you the only
Black man that owns
Champagne grapes in Champagne?
- I'm the only Black man, and
I'm the only American that
owns the grapes in Champagne.
As you know, they won't let
an American own land there.
- Right.
- So we own all the
rights to the grapes
that come off the land.
That allows us to give you
the first press of the grape.
And what I discovered is
that, here in America,
a lot of the Champagnes that we
get are second and third press.
Loaded with sugar.
Very high in sulfites.
So consequently, you get a
headache when you drink it.
This is our Le Champion,
and it is 100 percent pinot.
You probably won't find another
100 percent pinot in the United States.
And if you do, it's
maybe one or two of 'em.
- This is delicious.
You've had every single
job. You've been a coach.
You've been a GM. You've been
an owner. You've been a player.
When you were playing, did
you know, "When I get done,
these are the things that
I want to accomplish"?
- Even when I was playing,
I was what you might
call a serial entrepreneur.
I experimented a
lot, you know, in business.
And a lot of it came
around the city of Detroit
and in Michigan.
I started a candy bar called
Isiah Bar after the Reggie
Jackson bars, after
the Reggie! bar.
Put that on the shelf, and then
I partnered with Stroh's ice
cream.
Put Stroh's ice cream into the
supermarkets, into the shelf.
And then the next product,
as you talked about,
was popcorn, because
I love popcorn.
- Yep. Oh, I know it.
- So we—
- Get you outta that Times Square.
That popcorn was hittin'.
- Yeah.
- I'm a popcorn guy, man.
- Yeah, you remember that.
- I see why you
got a Champagne.
You're celebrating
all these wins.
You ain't got no losses.
- Well, this Champagne
is called Le Champion.
But you gotta look at
this color, Channing,
I'm always fascinated by how, you know,
the color of the Champagne is
and how tight the bubbles are.
And, Channing, you'll notice,
as this Champagne kinda settles
a little bit, it
gets a lot smoother.
And that's what I love
about this Champagne.
Some Champagnes you drink,
and you have a whole fight
in your mouth, where you—
- [Laughing]
- You know, you have to swish
it around and stuff—
- For sure.
- Before you can even swallow it.
- So, the Erath.
- When I first saw this, you know, I'm old and my eyes ain't so good, right?
But I play it off
cuz I don't
wanna put the glasses on, so.
- Right. Oh, yeah.
- So when I first looked
at it, I was like,
"Oh, this Earth Champagne."
I mean, "Earth wine."
I called it "Earth."
- Yeah, this is Earth,
Wind and Fire's wine.
- Yeah, yeah. Exactly, exactly.
- It only comes out in September.
- Ah, there you go.
That's nice. I like that.
- This is a white pinot noir.
Erath has been around and is
one of the better producers
in the Willamette Valley.
Whether that's smoke
or whether that's
something going
on with the skins of the grape—
- Mm.
- They have to take the
skins off and press, right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so you're getting the
essence of the pinot noir
without the color.
- Yeah.
- Let's go back just a little bit
farther. You told me a story.
You growing up, having
your coach in your house.
You're on your recruiting visit
with your mom and your brother
there.
- Yeah.
- Tell everybody that story, and
then I'll bring it back around
to this wine.
- So I'm assuming that you're
talking about Coach
Knight when I was
being recruited
to go to Indiana University.
And as you know, we were poorer than poor.
When Coach Knight came to visit,
we had no electricity.
And so when he came over,
all my brothers was there.
You know, my mom was there. And we had
been offered a lot of things
to go to different colleges. You know, money—
- Right.
- And, you know, cars and homes.
And again, we had nothing.
- Whew, blue chips! Blue chips!
- Yeah, I mean, Channing, I actually
turned down blue chips.
- It came back to you.
It came back.
- Yeah, so we got offered
all kinds of things, right?
And this one college
coach came to our house,
opened up a briefcase and said,
"Hey, there's $50,000 in here.
If your son comes to this
college, you get $50,000."
Now, Channing, we had never seen
$50,000 before in our life.
- Whew!
- As far as we know, it could have only
been $1,000 in that briefcase.
- Right.
- And so now, Coach Knight comes.
And I remember him
sitting there saying, you know,
"Mrs. Thomas, you know I'm only gonna
offer your son three things.
A. He's gonna get
a good education.
B. I'm gonna teach
him everything I know
about the game of basketball.
And C. He'll be a gentleman."
You know, I remember my brothers looking
at me and me looking at them, like,
"Well, OK.
Well, we're not
going to Indiana.
I mean, this is—"
- [Laughing]
- "This ain't gonna work,"
you know?
And so, Channing, so now
the lights are going down.
So it's getting
dark in the house.
And as it's getting a little
darker, you know, we had roaches, right?
- Yeah.
- So there's a roach that's crawling right
behind Coach Knight.
And I'm like, "Oh, please
go back. Please go back."
- [Laughing]
- And the roach is
crawling down the wall.
And I'm saying to
myself, "Oh, man, I
hope don't nobody see that
roach coming down the wall."
- [Laughing]
- So now, you know, the conversation gets,
you know, they get to talking about
where are you going to play.
And, you know, how's it going
to be at Indiana.
My mom asked Coach Knight, you know,
a pretty serious question.
She said, you know, the klan is
in Martinsville, Indiana.
If my son gets into
any type of issues,
who's going to protect him?
He said, well, if we're
winning, Mrs. Thomas, the klan
will protect him.
[Both laughing]
- Oh, my God.
He said that to your mother?
- Yeah, but, you know, in a joking kind of
way, right?
My brother's like you. Like,
he didn't think that was a joke.
- [Laughing]
- So he was like, yo, what the
- Yeah, yeah.
- F you mean, so forth and so on.
Coach Knight was like, well, you know,
it's just a joke and dah, dah…
And so now I look over at
my brother, and he's lit.
Now he ready to fight.
And Coach Knight says
something back to him.
And then he said, well, you know, if
you wanna do something now,
we can take this outside.
And I never forget, Coach Knight
got up, took his jacket off,
rolled up his sleeves
- [Laughing]
- and said, yeah, we
can go outside.
And so now the whole
house is in an uproar, right?
My mother is sitting there,
And, you know, I'm looking at her
for her reaction, right?
- For guidance, like,
what am I supposed
to do with this?
- Yeah, and she's sitting
there like this…
And I'm like,
- [Laughing]
- oh, no.
She like him. Right?
And so it didn't
get into nothing.
You know, they broke it up and everything.
And my mom had a
press conference.
I was sitting next to her.
And she said, my son
has made his decision.
He's decided that he's
going to Indiana University
to play for Coach Bob Knight.
And I was sitting
there like this.
But it turned out to be one of the best
decisions
- You had no choice.
- she made.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
Here's what I'll say about that.
Both of us have been
coached by amazing coaches
- Mhm.
- throughout our NBA career,
throughout our college career.
And one thing they
didn't do was look at us
based on our skin.
They looked at us as
men. They looked at us
as how can they, how
could I make them better.
- Yes.
- Like, how can I,
how can they make the other
pieces that I have better, right?
And I feel like, when
you have an opportunity
to have a vineyard, right, and
things don't go the exact way.
You're looking at: How can
I still tell this story?
- Right.
- And so for me, this
white pinot noir
forever will be, whether it is
2015 or whether it's
or whatever year,
white pinot to me
is making the best out of
sometimes tough situations.
I think you're different, right, from a
lot of GMs or a lot of owners
and a lot of coaches.
Because they want to shy away
from the personal relationships
with players, right? That
is not business.
That relationship and that
trust is, some people just,
they put players on a carousel,
- Yeah.
- right? Without getting to know them.
And they wanna
talk—you can't talk
to each player the same way.
To tell you something
even crazier is
I still live in Portland.
You sent me where I've
lived for 14 years.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna open
up this last pinot.
When you were playing, who were guys
that you felt like you had to have the utmost preparedness
for and respect?
Obviously, it was Jordan.
Obviously, it was Bird.
Obviously, it was Magic.
But who were some of the
guys, some of the unknowns
that you were like, this
dude can go but just
doesn't get enough credit for it?
- The first name that
comes to mind right now
is Maurice Cheeks, who just
went into the Hall of Fame.
Now, Mo Cheeks is
from Chicago also.
And I remember when I
first came into the league, you know,
Philadelphia was rolling.
Channing, they was rolling.
I mean, he, Andrew Toney, you know,
Bobby Jones, Dr.
J, Moses Malone.
It was like, Lionel
Hollins, he was like, damn.
Like, where do we get a break?
You know, most guards would slide their
feet, but Mo Cheeks hopped—
- Yeah.
- You know. And so that gave him—
- [Laughing]
- That gave him an extra
quickness and an extra bounce.
And so I would go through my stuff,
nuh, nuh, nuh, nuh, nuh, nuh…nuh,
nuh, nuh…real hard between my legs.
Give my best shake,
and he'll say, huh.
[Laughing]
And I was like, oh, man.
- He'd just be, still be there.
- Still be there.
- Oh.
- And I couldn't shake him.
- Yeah, he's like…
- But he was the guy that gave me
the most problems defensively.
- These are stories
that I think we
need to continue to tell
about different players.
You know, in today's media, we always talk
about the top 20 or the top 50.
But each generation, there
are so many players that get
overlooked that had
a huge influence.
Like, there's no James Harden
if Manu Ginobili doesn't
come with that Eurostep first.
- Yes.
Yes.
- Right?
And that should be the story.
Like, James Harden is amazing, but
Manu Ginobili, like—and then here's
the truth.
We swept the Spurs in 2010.
You know who was the only dude
that we had to double-team?
It was Manu Ginobili when they
ran that
- Wow.
- sideline screen,
when they ran that 1-4, 1-5.
If you had to have, like, a
starting five of these dudes
are just hoopers who
don't get enough credit
from your generation, who would
they be, starting with guards?
- The coaching of today is
so drastically different
than it was back then.
I'm sure Magic Johnson would
have probably had two or three
coaches fired because the
coaches would have been looking
at him, like, oh, well,
you a 6'9" center
and you don't shoot the
three, so we can't play you
at the point guard position.
[Laughing]
You know?
- I mean, you're not wrong. I think…
- And so in this
era of basketball,
it would've been
interesting to see, you know,
who would've been successful
from our era in this era
and what positions would've
had to change
and who would have
the nerve as a coach
to change their coaching style
to make those guys successful.
- I think a lot of coaches coach
what makes them successful, not
coaching to win and what's
best for their players,
even though it's
uncomfortable for them.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And I think some coaches
go: "This is what I know.
This is what we're going to do."
Culturally, you can
do that as a coach.
But when it comes to the
skills and the talents
of your players, your
offense and defense
has to be 100 percent representative
of who's out there playing.
- Yeah.
- You're coaching.
You're not playing.
- How many players really
have in their vocabulary,
what you just articulated
is I'm playing to make
winning plays to win the game?
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- I'm not trying to cover
my ass for stats, right?
- I was the beginning of
the social media era.
- Right.
- What happened was, Zeke,
and you can attest to this.
When you would lose, in the
newspaper, they would say,
so-and-so lost, and
then that was it.
There wasn't no highlight
tape where you could cut it,
where you're dunking.
- Nope.
- You could be down 50, and people
are like, man, he's so good.
No, you're not good.
You're not winning.
- Yes.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- And so for me—
- You lost.
- Players are falling in love
with the fact—you lost.
- Yeah.
- You're a loser, right?
- That hurt, right?
If you weren't at the
championship game,
you weren't playing
at the Phoenix Suns' arena,
or America West Arena,
you didn't have all
the girls on you,
- Yeah.
- people were like, ugh.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- What are you, like, fourth?
Gross.
- Yeah.
- Right?
It hurt.
Hey, my dad used to
drop me off at six
in the morning at
this place called
Kiwanis Park in
Chandler, Arizona.
Cuz six in the
morning, he would
have me play against grown men.
- Yes.
- Right?
So now I'm 12, 13, 14.
I'm playing 30-year-old men.
- Yeah.
- I'm 6-foot-2.
They think I'm a little
bigger than what I am.
- That's where you learn
shot selection at.
- Yeah.
[Both laughing]
Well, that's where
you learn—listen,
you don't want to be somewhere
from 6 a.m. to 2 p.m.
and be sitting on the
side every single time.
- Yeah.
- To switch back to
this wine, right?
So this pinot noir is Granville.
It's the farmhouse cuvée.
Jackson is the man.
- Yeah, this is nice.
- Jackson is a second generation.
His dad was a grower.
He knows the Willamette Valley
like the back of his hand.
He's making it more new age.
This is a wine that is, like, the
middle-of-the-week wine, where
you're like, I just
wanna pure pinot noir.
- Mmhmm.
- I want what Willamette
Valley tastes like.
And this is it.
- It's a smooth, you know, goes down easy.
- There is no new oak on this.
And that, to me, is what
makes really good wine.
It's restraint.
And, for me, it's drinkable.
It's approachable.
It's, like, not, you don't feel a
certain way about it
except this is delicious.
- I remember one of my
first tastings, right?
And they said, you know,
spit it out, right?
And I was like, OK.
And I did that.
- [Laughing]
- As the day went on,you know,  you just
started smelling it, right?
- Oh, yeah.
- And what I didn't know
is that you can
get a high from smelling it, like.
- Oh, man.
Is that what got you
in the other industry?
- If you just walk around and
you're just smelling it,
you're like…
Actually, you know what got
me in the other industry?
In the cannabis
and the hemp space,
it's actually my son.
- Oh.
- My son and my daughter, you know,
they're younger, so.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- You know,
- You would assume.
- they indulge, right?
[Laughing] But then my son and
my daughter started saying,
hey, you know, you need to start
studying this a little bit more
because it helps
with my anxiety.
It helps with my depression.
- Right.
- My daughter has narcolepsy.
And, you know, I wore shoes today.
- Yeah, yeah. So show us those shoes.
- The Sleep Project.
Everybody should check it out.
But my daughter was
diagnosed with narcolepsy.
The doctors were saying,
hey, why don't you
try a little, you know, marijuana
for your depression
or your anxiety
- Right, right.
- or whatever.
That's when I really started
looking into the plant.
But I've gotten
into the business.
I'm vice chairman,
CEO of this company
called One World Pharma.
- If you had to get five
players from today's game
and play a seven-game series
against your bad boy Pistons,
who would those players be?
- The question is, what
rules are we playing by?
- We're playing by the '80s rules.
Your rules.
- Imma pick a team that
talent-wise would give us
a hard time.
- You would break them.
- Yeah, well, our mentality was…
- [Laughing]
- and what our defensive scheming
was, right? It all depends
on what coach
you putting with
these five players.
- Right.
- Because you just wasn't
going to beat us with talent.
We proved that against the
Lakers, Chicago and Boston.
- Right, right.
- You had to come with
a little bit more
than just the best
players because we're
going to make you think
for two-and-a-half hours
and for 48 minutes.
And if there's a weak
link on your team,
oh, we're going to exploit that.
- That type of mentality
is the most ferocious,
mentally grinding mentality.
- Yeah.
- And, like, you've proven that
that works only for y'all. Like,
- Yeah.
- you can't copy that style.
If you're talking the
top 25 best players ever,
- Yeah.
- you beat
- All of them.
- three of the top 10
and their teams.
All of them.
- All of them.
All them people that they say
are the best to ever do it,
- Yeah.
- my teams beat all of them.
You know, we probably was the
best defensive team
to ever play in the NBA.
Now they've showed you
some highlights of us.
They showed a few clips
of us fouling people hard,
and then they, you know, wrote a
few paragraphs around it.
And they said, OK,
this is the Pistons.
But when you go back and
you watch the Pistons play
and you talk to all the
coaches that you've played for,
all of them are trying
- Yeah.
- to emulate
the way we play defense.
- They tell you from
one perspective,
but they don't show
you the whole game.
- Still the highest-scoring game
ever in the NBA is held by who?
The Detroit Pistons
at 186 points.
- Ooh.
- That's what we scored
against the Denver Nuggets.
- Who were you playing?!
Grandmas and grandpas?!
- We was playing against
the Denver Nuggets.
186-184.
- You know what? It's the altitude.
It's the altitude.
- The highest-scoring
game ever, right?
How many games have
you actually seen
of the Detroit Pistons
in your lifetime?
Think about that.
- To be honest, off
top, I've only seen
clips of Dennis Rodman
doing his thing.
- Yeah, they show you a few clips—
- I've seen clips of you when
you hurt your ankle.
Right, but I've never—they don't really
show you guys as a whole,
even though you're champions.
- Those who haven't
become champions
can't understand that sacrifice,
don't understand that journey.
And therefore,
they lower the bar
and say that, "Oh, you were just lucky
to be on the championship team."
- I think we have the
greatest championship
in the history of basketball.
- 100 percent!
- Because we're the only—
- 100 percent.
- Yes. That's how I feel.
- Down 3-1 in the NBA Finals
to, historically, they
were saying one of
the greatest teams
to ever play and come
back and win the series.
That is the greatest feat
in NBA championship play
that I've ever
witnessed in my life.
- The basketball
game is 40 minutes,
but being a basketball
player is 24/7.
- 24/7.
- I talk to my wife four minutes.
- Yes.
- I say, "Hey, baby.
Hey, I love you, OK?
I gotta go back to my team."
- Yeah.
- We're stretching together.
We're eating together.
We're recovering together.
Even if somebody was
just getting a massage,
you'd have three, four
people in the room watching
film, talking, sitting.
- Yeah. Yep, yep.
- We were so close, right?
- Yes.
- And even to this day, we're
on the same text chain.
We still communicate.
- Same here.
- And I'm curious—to you, are
you still in communication?
Obviously with
Laimbeer you are.
But how many of your
teammates do you
talk to still after
all these years?
- We have a group text
where we text every night.
And in the text,
we'll say, "I love you."
We'll say, you know,
"F you."
- Yeah.
Right.
- Wishing each other happy birthdays.
What you just talked about, again,
in terms of that sacrifice,
that discipline.
How many players are
willing to make that?
- Bron plays for lineage.
Bron plays for Mount
Rushmore of NBA.
This man plays every game
to try to be the greatest
player of all time.
So when you look at his
schedule and how he eats,
how he approaches a game, what
he knows, what he doesn't know,
how he talks is on
a level that when
you humble yourself and
say, "OK, you are different"—
- Yeah.
- Then you can accept
who he is and why
he acts the way he does.
- I'm gonna give
you two stories and—
to punctuate what you
just said about LeBron.
But I said to him,
I said, "You know, you have
to accept the challenge of
trying to be the greatest
player to ever play.
Because not many of us,
including myself, has ever
had the opportunity to play
for being the greatest
player to ever play.
Fast-forward, right?
He asked me, "OK, where do I—"
I said, "You got, you gotta
become smarter at the game."
I said, "The brain
is a muscle, so you
have to start reading
before the game.
So when it's time for
you to go out and play,
your brain is firing."
- You're the one
that told him that.
- I'm the one that told him that.
Who are the players
that we had to beat?
So Magic Johnson, Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar, they
thought like LeBron James.
They understood that type
of detail in the game.
- Right.
- Larry Bird, Dennis Johnson, they
understood that type of detail
in the game.
So when you talk about
playing against those guys,
Channing, in my era,
we had three teams,
in terms of Philly,
Boston and L.A.,
that they had two to three
guys on their team that
thought like LeBron.
That's how good
those teams were.
- To beat those teams, you had to
have your own unique hot sauce, right?
- Yeah.
- You couldn't use somebody
else's sauce on their chicken.
- The hot sauce had to
come from your brain.
- You had to bring your
own type of sauce.
Exactly.
- Hey, man, like I said, you can
run fast, you can jump high,
you can dunk—you
can do all that stuff.
But if you can't think? Oh, we
gettin' ready to kill you.
- Yeah.
What do you want people to
think about your legacy?
- I would say, as a person
overcoming all the obstacles
and the odds of growing
up on the West Side
below the poverty
line. I was the kid
that wasn't supposed
to make it to 18,
wasn't supposed to
graduate from college,
get into UC Berkeley
and get a master's in education.
I was the kid that strived
to get out of the ghetto,
strived to get out of hard times.
And then I happened
to play basketball.
Your personhood, your honesty,
your trust, your sacrifice,
your discipline.
Like, you know, who are you as a person?
And I would want
people to remember me
as the person I was, not
necessarily the basketball
player I was.
Because if all you
can remember me for
is that I was a good
basketball player, then
I've done a bad job with
the rest of my life.
- Thank you, man.
I mean, Zeke, obviously, like, I would
do this for hours with you.
I appreciate your time.
You're the best.
Thanks for being on "Full-Bodied."
- Thank you.
And I love you, and
I really mean that.
- I love you, too, man.
You're the best.
- Thank you.
♪♪♪